a very good way to understand
probability is by looking at outcomes of
the throw of a dice assume a fair dice
is thrown let's think of all the
possible
outcomes you may get one 2 3 4 5 or six
these are the only possible outcomes for
one throw of a
dice in numerical form we write it as 1
2 3 4 5 and 6
here's a first question what is the
probability of getting a one remember we
need two things to find the
probability first how many ways in which
the event can occur and second what are
the total possible outcomes there is
only one way in which we can get a one
that is if the dice lands a one and in
all there are six possible outcomes it
means that the probability of getting a
one at one one throw of a dice is 1x 6
here's the next
question what's the probability of
getting a three there is only one way in
which we can get a three and yes there
are six possible
outcomes the probability of getting a
three is also 1 16 since the
probabilities are the same we say that
these two events are equally
likely until now in all the problems we
have seen the numerator has always been
one one when will the numerator not be
one let's zoom out a bit to see the next
question what would be the probability
of getting an even number at the throw
of a dice now it gets interesting we
have to look at all possibilities in
which we can get an even
number there are three ways in which we
can get an even number we may get a two
or four or six yes at one throw I will
get just just one number not three but
remember the numerator tells us the
number of ways in which an event can
occur and it can occur in three ways and
in all there are six possible outcomes
the number of all possible outcomes for
a throw of one dice won't change it is
the numerator that will change in view
of what has been asked so it will equal
3x6 this can also be reduced to half but
we keep it at 3x6 for now let's see one
last question related to a throw of a
dice what will be the probability of
getting an odd number three outcomes can
result in an odd number 1 3 or five it
means that there are only three ways in
which the dice can land an odd number
either a one or a three or a five and
the total possibilities remain six the
probability will equal 3x 6 so these two
events are also equally likely it means
that if we throw a dice once the
likelihood of getting an even number is
the same as the likelihood of getting an
odd number can you think of an example
where two events are not equally likely
we will see that example in the next
video